Speaker 1: Let's go to Grant from Iowa City,
Iowa.
Grant, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I saw your interview
with Ben Dixon yesterday.
It was interesting.
Thank you.
It's clear that the Christian nationalist
movement is definitely growing or at least
becoming more bold.
Yes.
And so I was just wondering I know I don't
know if you identify as like agnostic or atheist,
I'm not sure.
But so I don't know how much interaction like
personally you've had with evangelical conservative
Christians.
But do you think not the politicians, but
like just like general people in public, you
think they're motivated more by a desire for
power, or are they motivated more by fear?
Personally, in my experience, I kind of grew
up in that kind of, you know, realm.
And I think there's a there's a great fear
they have obviously afraid of like God punishing
them.
Speaker 1: So I my my most extensive interactions
with American evangelicals was when I went
to Indiana because my girlfriend has family
there.
And the my my girlfriend's Jewish.
But is she has a part of her family that's
evangelical Christians.
And what I saw in speaking to them, a lot
of fear and a lot of fear driven, conspiratorial
beliefs.
And it did not feel to me like.
Now I'm not talking about politicians.
I'm talking about random people.
Which was your question?
It did not really a thirst for power.
Was there a guiding light?
It genuinely seemed like it was fear.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just interesting to me because I think.
Just in my own experience, like when I went
to college and stuff and just, you know, classes
were for looking at other groups in the world.
And I was like, Oh, this is not that scary.
And.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
And, like, I don't know, even just like, I'm
still Christian, but like my view of, like,
God has changed so much from what it used
to be.
It just like this was angry God who wanted
to punish us any time he could.
So I know I kind of think I've enjoyed talking
with more conservative Christians and evangelicals
over the last few years because I kind of
like just get to know how they're feeling
about stuff and and perspectives.
And for some of them it seems like, Oh, okay,
they start to learn like it's it's not as,
you know, horrifying as it might be, I guess,
to.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's really interesting to hear
in that you came to that conclusion because
one of the things that I've thought about
is, you know, I guess I guess I consider myself
agnostic, although whenever I explain my views,
people will write in and they'll say, David,
you're actually an atheist, whatever.
Call me whatever you want.
But my view is I think it's completely possible
that some kind of God or higher power exists.
I've just not seen any evidence of it.
But one of the things that I've come to believe
is contrary to much of this fire and brimstone
stuff from the evangelical side, if there
were such a higher power, it seems to me that
if God created such complicated human beings,
God would not be this black, white, vindictive
arbiter that some Christianity makes him out
to be.
And it sounds sort of like you've come to
the same idea.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
So, well, I can let you get some other people
now.
All right.
But I just thank you so much.
Speaker 1: I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: And in fact, what Grant from Iowa
is letting me do is just end the segment because
we are at the end of our time today.
I always am just so broken up that I cannot
get to everyone who's waiting to talk to me.
But that means that hopefully next week some
people will call in.
So I will speak to you then.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
more right after this.